OMT was developed at General Electric corporation by James Rumbaugh and
others that were there. It resulted in a book, a cover of a book as a,
a die on which there are three visible faces. And
one face has a class model diagram, one face has a state chart diagram, and
one face has a data flow diagram. The class model gave you
the structural aspects, the state chart gave you the behavioral aspects, and
the data flow diagram gave you the functional aspects.
That is OMT was a way of putting together three views of
a system into a cohesive view. As OMT was coming along other competitive,
object-oriented methods and diagrams were also being developed.